[Musique]
double événement ce vendredi 8 octobre
dans les hauts de saint-paul où deux
chemins d'exploitation ont été inaugurés
tout d'abord au chemin bras mort ou deux
kilomètres ont été bétonné et sécuriser
les travaux été cofinancé par le
département et l'union européenne à
hauteur respectivement de 10 % et 2 75%
des travaux pour un investissement total
de près de un million neuf cent mille
euros ces jeux marron permettre aux
agriculteurs déjà de mieux travailler
puisque étant donné que vous comprenez
bien que sur le
si les chemins sont pas bétonner l'accès
difficile l'exploitation reste
compliquée notamment dire pour aller
vite familles de ces agriculteurs nous
avons des habitudes qui ont des enfants
dont ils ont besoin d'avoir l'accès vers
les bas qu'ils soient améliorées le
département si elle se soucie
d'irrigation dont nous allons
accompagner de les hauts de l'ouest sur
l'éducation pour amener l'eau pour
l'exploitation la productivité
l'inauguration on veut que les
aviculteurs mariner soit innovant qui
puisse amener au renier ni réellement un
fonctionnement au tout le monde et
ressentie quand je dis ça c'est que
l'action l'alimentation la réunion doit
être capable de produire pour les
réunionnais la deuxième session
inaugurale s'est tenue au chemin furcy
du vernet nouvellement aménagée sur près
de 3 km les travaux qui font le bonheur
des riverains nouvellement desservis
mais surtout celui des agriculteurs
mais avant tout les chemins je m'étais
qu'alimentaire la difficulté pour lui qu
on entend gagner c'était beau livre est
là quand j'apprends avec l'appui même
que le matériel tout ça pour travailler
tes paraît pas évident là comme la
aujourd'hui à l'appui donc l'alpinisme
et cannes
actuellement et même pas les rives rsa
n'était pas évident pour descendre le
chemin et avec l'arrivée de l'autre sens
on a pu mettre de l'eau dans les espaces
d'une culotte on y tient à remercier
ben toutes les équipes se connecter et
l'europe où ça pour le chemin bah ouais
c'est une révolution
avant ça bon achat de 38 5 cyclones et
forêts à tous le chemin déjà au niveau
des transporteurs il voulait pas trop
trop enlevée lac entre le rapport le
chemin
robert est maintenant
là aussi le département s'est mobilisé
les côtés de la ville de saint-paul
d'une part en mobilisant les fonds
feader hauteur de deux millions deux
cent mille euros en sa qualité
d'autorité de gestion de ce fonds
européens et sur ses fonds propres à
hauteur de 300 mille euros
[Musique]